Arnaud demande Arnaud qui vient avec
nous bonjour Arnaud
[Rires]
un petit passage de relais joyeux
anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
bah dis donc
vous avez de la chance Thomas une
attraction de Caro et une un parc
américain visité par Jérémy Wagner qui a
découvert un gros problème sur la
structure
une énorme fissure sur l'un des pylônes
l'homme a posté cette vidéo et des
photos sur facebook après avoir prévenu
les pompiers les autorités et la
sécurité du parc qui a rapidement fermé
le manège des travaux sont en train
d'être effectués une catastrophe a
sûrement été évitée aujourd'hui il y a
des petits malins qui ont mis des clous
voilà 3 4 5
merci voilà merci pour ce genre de
conneries humaines ajoute même le
français dans son poste sur Twitter il y
en calme jeune scandalisé je le cite
encore sachez qu'on peut tomber et se
faire très mal avec vos conneries bandes
abruti un homme c'est marié donc avec
une femelle caïman oui et pas n'importe
quel homme le maire d'une ville située
au sud du Mexique où habite la
communauté indigène Chantale c'était il
y a quelques jours donc en public bien
sûr avant la cérémonie la femelle
crocodile s'est promener de maison en
maison pour danser avec les habitants
comme vous le voyez elle s'était mis sur
son 31 regardez jupe verte petit chapeau
coiffe délicate fait de rubans et de ce
qu'un coloré
ne gémissez pas assez
alors là une histoire de dingue du
couleur rapport était ennuyeux alors il
justifie sa demande en expliquant qu'en
conséquence il ne profite pas du mariage
c'est seulement ensuite que le reptile
c'est à enfiler sa robe blanche argentée
pour se rendre à la mairie moment
émouvant ou le maire lui a
solennellement déclaré sa flamme
j'accepte d'épouser cette princesse
a-t-il dit parce que nous nous aimons
voilà le Cayman n'a pas répondu mais à
l'issue de la cérémonie émotion
applaudissement nourri du public les
jeunes mariés se sont embrassés et tout
le monde semblait parfaitement heureux
par contre de son côté Charlotte
l'épouse a déclaré que son mari avait
des relations extra-conjugales et qu'il
était en train d'inventer toute cette
histoire pour qu'elle quitte la maison
et le laisse libre sans avoir à payer de
pension c'est une tradition en fait dans
ce village depuis plus de 230 ans Marie
des hommes avec les reptiles c'est comme
ça depuis que deux ethnies qui se sont
qui se détestaient se sont réconciles
grâce à un mariage alors pour cette
communauté s'unir un caïman c'est
réactiver ce moment c'est se connecter à
la terre c'est aussi une façon d'appeler
la pluie pour les récoltes l'histoire ne
dit pas si l'astuce est efficace
mais les bébés dans votre maman d'après
moi aussi c'est grossiste c'est tous les
gens qui continuent à m'appeler elle
ça me frappe
parce que
je pense que c'est au-delà de
la gentillesse c'est juste un manque de
respect
une façon privilégier votre confort
plutôt que mon bonheur
S
[Musique]
ma socialisation elle est difficile
parce que vous m'appelez elle en fait à
toutes les 5 minutes et ça me blesse en
fait
ça me blesse en fait
vous voulez du réel je suis réel tu
viens de voir sur scène tu sais que je
suis réel tu écoutes ma musique tu sais
que c'est ce que je pense que ce que je
dis c'est pour ça que les gens après se
permettre autant d'être intrusif avec
moi vous voulez quelqu'un qui pleure
ça fait du mal en fait
je pense que c'est la chieuse de la
semaine
[Musique]
on parlait d'assimilation comment
voulez-vous
assimile à une société on n'arrive plus
à distinguer un homme d'une femme c'est
vertigineux une société parce qu'on
s'assimule on s'assimule pas un asile
d'aliénée on s'assimile à une équipe de
foot qui gagne ça c'est mille pas à une
société qui respire cette maladie et je
suis je suis je compatis beaucoup avec
cette dame parce que il y a une
souffrance je retire le mot que vous
avez dit cette femme n'est pas une
aliénée
c'est la nuance entre la gentillesse et
un vœu pieux n'est-ce pas que tu viens
de formuler un soudanais surpris en 2006
en train de coucher avec une chèvre
l'homme tente de nier de s'excuser mais
face à l'évidence de la relation la
communauté le contrat de se marier avec
la chèvre alors à l'époque la punition
réjouit un certain nombre de zoophiles
qui parlent d'une avancée majeure pour
leur cause punition qui laisse en
revanche les associations de protection
des animaux songeur commence à voir si
la chèvre était consentante car si ce
n'est pas le cas c'est double peine pour
cette chèvre qui est contrainte à se
marier avec son agresse la serre est
certes allumée de jour mais figurez-vous
qu'elle est aussi allumée de nuit
les tomates continuent de pousser
pendant que les habitants dorment
l'environnement prend des allures de
décors de science-fiction je pensais pas
du tout que c'était à ce point là c'est
tout est éclairé quoi tout le ciel est
éclairé oh là là c'est la priorité
surtout donc du coup la moitié soit
capable de cohabiter avec les chiens ils
sont sociables et ils s'adapte à tout le
monde mais des gens qui n'aiment pas
et donc c'est ça va paraître
complètement fou mais c'est eux qui vont
décider un peu les chiens
et donc ça c'est toutes les nuits oui
toutes les nuits 4 5 mois de l'année à
partir de décembre en fait en hiver ici
à plus de nuit les jours tout le temps
exactement c'est ça il fait jour toute
la nuit pour les animaux ça doit être
perturbant aussi oui les oiseaux ils
doivent se demander ce qui se passe un
petit peu on les entend de temps en
temps les oiseaux chantent la nuit
depuis qu'il y a cet éclairage
quand on est passé exactement près de la
serre